uh
ron why did you throw that wood away
it's unstable it's no good
i just don't understand the throwing
away the wood metaphor
what's the lesson oh i know it's potty
training
that trash can is the toilet and the
wood was the pieces chris i'm not
teaching you
anything we're just building a crib no i
know you're not
consciously teaching me anything i'm
just trying to siphon off some of your
calm
centered wisdom through metaphors
metaphors
i hate metaphors that's why my favorite
book is moby dick
no frou-frou symbolism just a good
simple tale about a man who hates an
animal
that's enough for today i think
an organized child no
ron what's this the crib i built
i'm giving it to you and anne it's
perfectly safe i tested it by hitting it
with my truck
well ron i can't accept this is for your
baby there's more than one
crib tree in a forest that's not a
lesson by the way just a comment
on lumber availability it's beautiful
thank you
nobody has all the right answers in
parenting including me
and that toxic crib you bought won't be
the last mistake you make
but a man who is this worried about
making all the right choices
cares very much that's all that matters
you'll be a great father thank you ron
for the crib and the advice it's much
better than any metaphor
does the white whale actually symbolize
the unknowability and meaninglessness of
human existence
yeah no it's just a fish
i now officially insist that you take a
sabbatical no no let me finish
i used to work in a sheet metal factory
but then
a job came along at the tannery the
hours were better and i would get paid
also i'd have the chance to work with
leather both before and after it was on
the cow which
had always been a dream of mine i didn't
want to give up my sheet metal job so i
tried to do both jobs
and finish middle school how old were
you 11.
the point is i was so tired i tried to
puncture an 8 gauge aluminum foil
with a leather awl
[Laughter]
wow i learned a lesson never half-ass
two things whole ass one thing
so if you want to win that seat which i
do
then commit yourself 100
take a sabbatical breakfast nope
oh i don't know come on
there has never been a sadness that
can't be cured by breakfast food
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
wait wait i worry what you just heard
was
give me a lot of bacon and eggs what i
said was
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
do you understand
ron what do you say dynamic duo get
together one more time to try to save
jj's diner
i can't think of anything more noble to
go to war over than bacon and eggs
thank you darling why would anybody ever
eat anything besides breakfast food
people are idiots leslie
[Music]
behold the swanson pyramid of greatness
i've been developing the swanson pyramid
of greatness for years
it's a perfectly calibrated recipe for
maximum personal achievement
categories include capitalism god's way
of determining who is
smart and who is poor crying acceptable
at funerals and the grand canyon rage
poise property rights fish for sport
only
not for meat fish meat is practically a
vegetable haircuts there are three
acceptable haircuts
high and tight crew cut buzz cut are the
scissors broken in your house son
this mural is called bad pawnee good
pawnee
all the terrible things that have
happened in this town's history are on
one side
and on the other side are all the good
things that have happened
i'm on the bad side no you're not yes i
am ron i'm guilty i did something bad
i'm a bad person it's not that simple
you know what makes a good person good
when a good person does something bad
they own up to it they try to learn
something from it
and they move on i literally have 1 000
questions
why is ron wearing headphones what's
when she's club and what is anne
complaining about
you mostly how you never let her vent
because you're always too busy trying to
solve everything for her
she's upset that i'm trying to help her
you've fallen into a classic trap
christopher
trying to fix a woman's problems instead
of just listening to what they are
why are you yelling tom put all my
records into this rectangle
do you fish april no she sucked gross
let me give you a piece of fishing
advice i said i don't when you have a
fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose
especially if he's a nice fish with a
big lovable fish heart you
don't know what you're talking about
maybe not maybe
you really do hate andy maybe moving to
indianapolis just to get revenge on him
is a really good idea what do i know
you're on the air hi uh what's wrong
with joan
she has a bad hangover which she is
pretending as
allergies is she gonna be okay wouldn't
know
never been hung over after i've had too
much whiskey i cook myself a large flank
steak pan-fried and salted butter i eat
that put on a pair of wet socks and go
to sleep
that works it does please call now if
you have questions about tonight's gala
or one of my other interests woodworking
uh novels about tall ships meat
that sort of thing i honestly don't care
but i'm just gonna say it i like joe
he's a nice man who's good with kids and
he seems to be smart and patient
i know that's why he's my tammy i'm a
social butterfly
when we're together all we do is have
sex sit on the couch
eat homemade pasta have sex again enough
he's constantly being respectful wanting
to spend time with me
trying to connect with me it's a
nightmare i become
boring live your life how you want
but don't confuse drama with happiness
so while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking i'm not street parking my
mercedes well everyone is i'm doing it
cause nobody wants to steal a saturn all
right uh moving on to recycling
you okay ron just a little tooth pain
i'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist ron i
don't like dentists
just a second hey
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about
recycling dentist pulled the tooth out
yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers
that you are capable of withstanding a
tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see tom faint
you